hold on hold on people stop the Jeep
ride just stop it yo John Williams cut
music Steven Spielberg you should know
better if I'd made this mistake the
internet would be running me out of town
on a rail come on Stevie the Triceratops
Velociraptor and t-rex aren't from the
Jurassic period meaning that the park
should be called Cretaceous world hey no
one said scientific accuracy was catchy
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
founding members of the Chris Pratt
appreciation Club I mean seriously this
guy can do no wrong in my eyes well
except for maybe passengers
yeah and for totally causing the
universe to get dusted but seriously
this guy is my perpetual man crush
Monday attention all you internet
shippers here's the new hashtag hashtag
Pratt pads so of course as Chris Pratt's
biggest - totally not creepy totally not
a stalker fan you know that I'm excited
about the new jurassic world fallen
kingdom I mean what is not to love about
a Six Flags full of dinosaurs yeah sure
but that was just growing pains Jurassic
world open to the public and had okay
fine fine filling a park with
bloodthirsty prehistoric beasts may not
be the safest choice which begs the
question then is a dino park really
doomed for failure multiple casualties
and more lawsuits than you can shake a
shirtless Jeff Goldblum at and the
answer is a decided no for as difficult
as it might seem to run a park like this
all of it and I do mean all of it could
have been easily avoided if the people
running the park had just done some
basic research right you are - I'd Nick
Fury the Jurassic park's do in fact have
all the problems of a mega sized zoo
coupled with the danger factor of an
amusement park but after studying all of
the Jurassic Park films yes even
Jurassic Park 3 I've come to the
conclusion that three simple fixes could
have completely reversed the course of
all of these movies resulting in
hundreds of lives saved and also a few
billion less at the box office but who's
counting so get ready
today we're learning how Jurassic world
should protect when dinos attack first
we have to talk space now this should
come as no surprise but wild animals
need space in captivity to thrive if an
animal is kept in an enclosure that's
too small well things are gonna start to
get a little hairy or I suppose if
you're keeping a dinosaur scaly feathery
at this point is it feathery now is it
feathering out anyway the association of
zoos and aquariums or aza created a
manual with the basic tenets of how to
treat animals in confinement / the
manual there are strict minimums for the
amount of space needed for each species
based on their size
for example a lion needs a minimum of
10,000 square feet a little over the
size of a baseball diamonds infield or
five tennis courts if that sounds like a
lot well consider this in the wild a
typical Lions territory is a hundred
square miles everything the light
touches is our kingdom that's nearly
three hundred thousand times more than
what's being given to them in captivity
but okay if this is the standard for
keeping animals happy in captivity in a
humane way we can apply similar metrics
to a dinosaur and thus approximate the
minimum amount of space needed to keep
these ancient creatures in check so the
biggest lions are about 4 foot by 8 foot
in size meaning that for every 32 square
feet a lion he needs 10,000 square feet
to roam freely her scientists the
average t-rex was just a wee bit bigger
at 18 feet by 40 feet so for the 720
square feet that a t-rex covers he's
gonna need 32 over 10,000 equals 720
over X a minimum of 225 thousand square
feet to thrive that is nearly 5 acres of
land for one Thunder lizard to put it in
jock terms that is four and a half
football fields for one animal so how
well does Jurassic world do when it
comes to giving its star attractions the
appropriate amount of space well we
never actually see the full size pen for
the t-rex but we do get to see it for
his genetic mutant brother the I Rex a
correction we kinda get to see it you
see the movie can't really decide if the
I rex paddock is a hexagon or an octagon
maybe they should have spent less time
focused on the height of the walls 40
feet high but okay we can do some quick
calculations to figure this thing out
first based on this exterior shot of the
paddock being reinforced we can see that
it's shockingly small actually we just
heard that the walls are 40 feet high so
by using pixel measurements we can
calculate that this side of the paddock
is a little less than a hundred feet
long and the whole thing is shaped like
a regular octagon so it's not gonna be
that big that seems absurdly small so
let's double check those numbers at 35
minutes 12 seconds into the movie you
can see that they're at a bend in the
paddock with the scratches on the
adjacent wall 30 seconds later we
owen enter the paddock with the claw
marks directly across from the team
since the overhead map shows us that the
shape of the paddock is a regular
octagon that would mean that they're
entering here and walking across to here
once they get the call to evacuate it
takes my prati pi 8 seconds to sprint
towards the exit only to then be cut off
at the halfway point by the iraq's
they turn around running for their lives
sprinting at top speed except apparently
taking a bit more leisurely of a jog
this time since now it takes exactly 29
seconds for Owen to get to the door that
he just ran away from 8 seconds prior
man it's almost as if between the
Jurassic name the inconsistent paddock
shape and now chris pratt's variable
running speed it's almost like the movie
doesn't care if it gets the details
right now that couldn't be it anyway the
top sprint speed for an average human is
16 miles per hour though Chris Pratt
you'll never be average to me meaning
that the total length they'd be running
from entrance to exit is about 90 feet
once you factor in the octagonal shape
getting cut off at the halfway point etc
etc anyway long story short these
shockingly small dimensions of the IREX
panic unbelievably check out so with
wall lengths of a hundred feet the area
of the pen winds up being 40 8284 square
feet that is the size of one football
field - the end zones it is one-fifth
the recommended size for a creature that
large even if you were to double the
size of the paddock as it currently
stands you would still be at less than
half of what this creature needs to be
kept humanely
there's even an in-universe explanation
for why this pen would be so incredibly
tiny
so they adjusted the height of the walls
to accommodate it being bigger but they
didn't actually adjust the size of the
paddock it's no wonder the indominus rex
was scratching up the walls going crazy
it was living in the Dino equivalent of
a tiny house and it's not just the size
of the enclosure that matters but also
the design within that enclosure again
per the aza Manual quote careful
consideration should be given to exhibit
design so that all areas meet the
physical social behavioral and
psychological needs of the species
animals should be displayed whenever
possible in exhibits replicating their
wild habitat end quote basically what
it's saying is the best way to
keep an animal happy in confinement is
to trick it into believing it's not
actually in confinement go figure
big surprise but yet again Jurassic
world fails to meet these absolutely
basic standards the aquatic Mosasaurus
is kept in a huge deep tank that
spectators watch from underground
there's only one problem with that
though her historical record the
Mosasaurus was actually more comfortable
in shallower waters putting it in a deep
water tank is the exact opposite of what
this animal needs but the oversight that
really comes back to mitem in a very
literal sense is with the Raptors you
see we always visualized dinosaurs
roaming around in dense tropical forests
and for the most part that's largely
true for example the majority of all
t-rex fossils were found in North
America the most famous being in the
Hell Creek Formation in the Wyoming
Montana area now Montana might seem like
a far cry from a tropical paradise but
remember we're talking about billions of
years ago North America back then was
thought to be fairly hot and humid
during the Cretaceous period so putting
a Dino theme park on a tropical island
like Isla Nublar which according to the
movies is 120 miles west of Costa Rica
with an average temperature of 75
degrees Fahrenheit and 80% humidity well
it's a pretty darn good choice for the
t-rex in fact it's a good choice for
most of the dinosaurs except for the
velociraptors you see Raptor fossils
were found closer to Mongolia this area
was much more dry and arid during
Cretaceous period for the Raptors to
feel comfortable in a tropical
environment like Isla Nublar they would
need to be placed in the equivalent of a
zoos desert exhibit but looking at the
Raptor enclosures to Rasik world has
made zero attempts at recreating their
natural environments imagine putting a
polar bear in a jungle it would be
completely crazy unless of course you're
in some sort of tropical island
post-death purgatory State
Oliver and yet that's pretty much
exactly what these so-called geniuses at
Jurassic world are doing so how do you
solve a problem like a raptor well you
train um the Aza manual recommends using
what's known as operant conditioning
where behaviors are encouraged or
discouraged through rewards and
punishments for example rats were put in
a cage with two buttons green and red if
rats press the green button they got
food but if they press the red one they
received a mild electric shock worst
experiment for them ever through this
type of positive and negative
conditioning the rats learn to only
press the green button for food
real-world zoo and aquarium employees
use similar tactics to teach animals how
to behave reducing the potential for any
sorts of conflict and it would seem like
this is exactly what Owen is doing with
the Raptors Owen uses a clicker to
control them if the dinosaurs respond
Owens click they're rewarded with food
in essence training them through
positive operant conditioning Oh Chris
you're such a clever girl but apparently
not clever enough sorry Chris I still
stand you hashtag Pratt pet forever but
I'm telling you this cuz I don't want
you to become a dinos Monty Chris doe oh
god that was bad for even me you see you
keep pushing the clicker you push it
repeatedly to get the Raptors attention
according to zoologist to actually use
this technique all you're gonna do is
just confuse the animals one click one
reward if you want to get the animals to
respond with special enthusiasm for an
action you should increase the rewards
associated with a single click like
giving it more food you don't increase
the number of clicks more clicks only
dilute the positive reinforcement you've
already conditioned the animal for which
honestly is gonna explain my Owens
control over the Raptors doesn't always
work very well
[Music]
looks like someone needs to get better
at click baiting I gotta say I'm proud
of that one now obviously all this seems
like a lot to fix trained dinosaurs to
respond to positive and negative stimuli
increased their living space and design
each habitat for each dinos individual
needs but there's already a real-world
counterpart that's done exactly these
things well without the dinosaurs that
is the Kilimanjaro safari at Disney's
Animal Kingdom it's actually kind of
crazy the amount of work that went into
this tour animals are set loose and
allowed to quote-unquote roam free and
open spaces designed for each species
but it's all a magic trick it's all an
illusion hidden moats and rock
formations sprinkled throughout the park
separate carnivorous animals from their
potential prey which includes humans
keeping the animals in check while still
keeping them happy and on display the
rocks where the Lions hang out totally
air-conditioned seriously there are air
conditioning blowers built into these
things and if it gets cold to have
heaters built in - which encourages the
Lions to hang out in plain view to
encourage the animals to be more active
Disney installed concrete feeders hidden
as elements in the environment like
broken tree limbs and rocks and as far
as operant conditioning is concerned at
the end of every day each animal has
been specially trained to respond to
different sounds the crocodiles have a
metal bar that's being hit underwater
elephants come in to the beat of a drum
- Raph's listen for a cowbell and a duck
call is used for the gazelles it's the
perfect example for Jurassic world to
follow Isla Nublar is a whopping 30
square miles in size so there is plenty
of room Owen gets good as a trainer they
add in some controlled climates easy as
that no deaths no lawsuits long story
short if you find yourself buying a zoo
of any type prehistoric or otherwise
just learn how the animals behave it'll
save a lot of lives or I don't know you
could just sell the whole thing to
Disney but something tells me that
Universal ain't gonna be doing that
anytime soon but hey that's just a
theory ah film theory and if you want
more delicious Dino action well then
check out my collaboration with one of
my all-time favorite people on YouTube
Rosanna pansino in honor of the new
Jurassic world we got together to bake a
dinosaur fossil cake not only did I have
a blast nerding out with her
for Dino things the cake is and I cannot
emphasize this enough
the single best chocolate cake that I
have ever tasted I mean it's no thanks
to me I was literally no help at all but
seriously and I'm not just saying this
because I like Rosanna or anything her
crew literally had to stop me from
eating this thing when the cameras were
rolling it was incredible so if you're
in the mood for some incredible desserts
or just me acting like an idiot in the
kitchen hammer the box to the left or
otherwise chomp down on my Jurassic
world conspiracy theory video the box to
the right now if you'll excuse me I've
got to leave that Chris Pratt is at his
favorite cafe right now